we have a voicemail number that is
2192davidp
that number is available anytime if it's
2am
and you've got a hankering for leaving
me a voicemail
you can do it at 2192davidp
here is a caller as i unders this is a
complicated voicemail i believe that
this is
a white caller who is mad
that uh he is hating white people
because of left-wing shows i think
that's what he's saying
and there's also a cat in the background
second only
to having the david pakman show playing
in the background when you leave a
voicemail
is having an animal making noise in the
background let's take a listen
hey dude
do you realize that that i'm probably
not one of the only
but you're actually
not your show in itself
but you're radicalizing the left and in
a certain way
you know what i mean because i feel like
man like
it the the rotten
that you show in the efforts to show how
rotten
the the right is which they are
it's all white people
i don't want to hate white people i'm
half white myself i'm
half white half black but god damn man
i'm done with this [ __ ]
man i'm done with these crazy ass white
people always doing bull
and talking bull and trying to make a
bullet
it's ridiculous man it's dumb
like i can't stand these people like i
laughed
when i heard that that that
what's his name died
come on man
preach some love somewhere i i don't
know is this person
upset with me is he upset with what he
believes or disproportionately
white actors in the republican party
which of course would be accurate
is the cat upset with him that won't
stop
making noise in the background i don't
really know what to make of that call
it's very interesting but i i truly
don't know what to make of it maybe
someone can explain it to me
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
citibank wired 500 million dollars
by mistake and a judge says they can't
get it back
very interesting story after uh
an engine failure dozens of boeing
triple sevens have been grounded in the
united
states and japan and there is some very
interesting backstory here and we will
talk about all of it on the bonus show
and lastly there is a teachers union
that is now saying let's reopen schools
if the nfl could figure out how to do it
let's do it now of course the nfl also
had
very particular resources when it comes
to testing and other things
which it's unclear school districts
would have but it is a very interesting
shift we are seeing from
some school districts it'll be a good
opportunity
to review coronavirus numbers to look at
deaths hospitalizations vaccinations and
many other things
so all of those stories and more
happening today on the bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpacman.com
it's quick it's easy it's painless it's
cheap
and you can use the coupon code better21
to get a powerful discount off of the
membership of your choice
sign up at joinpakman.com we will see
you then and we've got a great week of
shows coming up for you this week